blast let me ask you this question
who's the artist that you have the most
songs with in the can
that we don't that that aren't out i
would probably say
that isn't bino it would have to be
mozzie i got a bunch of joins on mazzy
yeah you and mozzie loki is like jay-z
and r kelly before
before she got weird not for real like
you guys have
[ __ ] records man and that's another
project
i think of fans would love is a mozzie
blast project that would be crazy
yeah i'll be seeing that a lot on
twitter like mazzie and blast project
would be crazy but
shout out mozzie for sure what is it
about uh mazza you think that you guys
have such a great chemistry
um i just feel like i'm able to step
into his world and really like
speak on it from like a narrator
perspective and it's mostly
just hooks when i collab with them
anyway so i just feel like i'm able to
speak on that topic
and just give it an overall summary
that's
that's kind of how i look at it in a
hook form but um yeah the camera [ __ ] is
there for sure